reports now of a drug resistant fungus
circulating in our local hospitals
experts say it can be invasive it can be
dangerous but only a specific group of
people should be concerned sasha loftus
joins us live across the studio tonight
with more on what this all means
brian and denise medical experts say
this fungus isn't new but they're seeing
it more across the country and here at
home it's not something that would make
everyone sick but they tell me we can
all stop it from
spreading name but it's something
medical experts are watching for across
the country and here at home it's coming
it's emerging it's getting more cases
the nevada department of health and
human services says cases of the drug
resistant fungus are being investigated
at 16 hospitals and three skilled
nursing facilities in southern nevada as
of monday they need to be very aware
that they're looking for this dr carlos
j lopez says this is something he and
other physicians are watching for as
serious cases can cause dangerous
bloodstream infections it really was
just a matter of time until we saw it in
a healthcare facility here in southern
nevada but unlv assistant professor of
public health brian labis says it's
important to know this disease attacks
people who are already immunocompromised
it's not something we're going to see
spread into schools or workplaces or
anything like that it won't normally
make a healthy person sick but we can
all carry it so hand washing and overall
hygiene is important to keep those we
love safe i think we have the chance to
stop this getting into our communities
both labis and dr lopez say this disease
is treatable it just requires a more
specific strategy they say it's
important to catch it early people
suffering usually have a fever it does
require a specific lab test to identify